Shaq how are you I'm good I'm trying to
be like you you know they called me in
the nft space right the black garyvee
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
dailyvee what's good headed to Atlanta
the gift code event Shaquille O'Neal's
in the building I can't wait to see the
film of that because last time Jack
hugged me at the Super Bowl I felt like
accountable and that small man's massive
but he's massive in his brain and soul
so looking forward to that look forward
to chopping up with a couple hundred of
gift goat holders looking forward to
seeing my man E when I went to college
with 301 the spot you know a little
basketball love a lot of business q a
unveiling gift goat eight to the crew
it's gonna be a nice day and we're
flying in and out so Landing back here
in Newark at past midnight so it's gonna
be a grinder a little throwback to the
way we did it big shout out drock and uh
excited for today
yes
we're here landed in Atlanta Atlanta's
beautiful big gift gold event
Shaquille O'Neal
he's gonna have everybody hyped goats
are meeting each other right now it's
gonna be really good teams work really
hard big shout out to everybody on the
befriend side really excited about this
event kind of focused as you can tell
and ready to go and
mingle educate
create relationships connect with the
community
do my thing
really cool
[Music]
this place is crazy so it's just so good
to be with all of you
um
really really excited about the Q a I
think for a lot of people here Shaq
represents
what it represents for them obviously
you see a lot of basketball jerseys
people know that but I have a good sense
of this community is aware how
multi-dimensional Shack really is his
ambition is remarkable but his capacity
for giving is exceptional and so I
thought he would be a tremendous person
to be here so let's clap it up for Shaq
even before he gets here
we're really excited about the interview
you're about to get with Saladin and
Courtney from 1 37 p.m I want you to
really lean in and get a sense of The
Man Behind the art I'm gonna go do an
obligation real quick come right back
and we're going to get going with the
Hall of Fame human Shaquille O'Neal
thank you for being here I'm very
excited to get into it with skiing
Saladin he went from drawing on his
childhood home walls to designing
trading cards working with Brands like
Jordan the MLB the NFL and many more so
I'm excited to get into it
we are going to introduce the one and
only King solidine go baby
tell him
your best friend JP had gotten you your
first set of professional art supplies
um at what point did JP come into the
picture and can you give us little
background on him if anybody knows my
artwork
um I'm kind of known more for the JP to
money bear which is in the painting it's
more of my my logo so my best friend JP
um we met when I was probably about 14
to what 27 years old out of nowhere
brain cancer stage four from me playing
basketball to that time was just him
like literally motivating me to like
find my gift it was almost like he was
here to do that that's why JP the money
bear is in memoration of him he was such
a motivational person and tried to get
me on my direction before he left this
world well thank you so much Saladin for
coming here spending the day with us
sharing your story give it up one more
time for Saladin
and now we're going to get into some q a
so it's my pleasure to welcome the stage
the Creator and the CEO of V friends
Gary vaynerchuk and Champion athlete
entrepreneur investor and Global icon
Shaquille O'Neal
let's hear for the legend Shaquille
O'Neal
what was that
special guy right
can you hear me turn me up a little turn
me all the way up there we go la la la
la la
he forgot this man was a musical genius
I don't forget that album
Shaq how are you I'm good I'm trying to
be like you you know they called me in
the nft space right the black garyvee
[Laughter]
Jack it's such an honor to be doing this
with you thank you for doing this thank
you for being here with the gift goats
this is a representation of a small
community of 555 within the befriends
world let's clap it up for each other
first
the reason I spend a lot of time talking
about eighth place trophies is no one's
going to be great at anything if they're
not competitive number two I think the
other thing that almost everyone
struggles with on their path to
Greatness is 100 accountability it is
staggering to me how
obsessed people are with pointing
fingers and not thumbs it is scary to
watch people genuinely believe it's
everyone's fault but themselves in a
world where you can do anything you want
you can adjust
um and then and then the third one is
patience do you remember when you were
on SNL and your name was Bernard and uh
your dad was Tracy Morgan
and he was like
uh get your ass over here I'm gonna
spank your butt Bernard would you like
to reenact that scene yes yeah
[Applause]
yeah
let's go
unbelievable you're the [ __ ] best
this this was shot on SNL about 20 years
ago I don't want you I don't want you to
think this is some new [ __ ] all right
all right Bernard get your ass over here
humble spank your butt
[Laughter]
[Music]
times I gotta tell you get here on time
let's clap that up
foreign
that's awesome
don't ever do that again to not have
that on the bingo card I will kill you
my question is what role has kindness
played in building your success
my mother taught me a long time ago
cost you nothing to be nice when I first
became Shaq 18 19 years old I was
arrogant my mother and my father are
people you don't talk back to my father
said be careful who you step on
on your way to success
and my mother will say who the hell are
you oh that ended my arrogance she said
it's because you're starting to get all
this stuff doesn't make you better than
my man up there sitting next to her son
doesn't make me better than this guy
with the hat yeah you know so and then
my favorite word always be humble
so with me what you see is what you get
I don't like you know I do a lot of
random acts of kindness I don't like
bragging about it because that's not
what I'm about like I just like making
people happy the thing that I wish I had
the answer for
homelessness homelessness hurts my heart
the other day where were we the other
day we were in some City the other day
and we saw a guy eating dirt
where Baltimore yeah we're in Baltimore
and we came under the bridge and the guy
was eating dirt
and then I just went like I wanted to
just
you know so I'm always remain humble
remain kind that's here for Shaquille
O'Neal let's get up
look how big this [ __ ] dude is all
right
I love you brother
[Music]
don't kill him too much
[Applause]
[Music]
exercise
it's like 2 000 on eBay
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go
what's most important to you as the
project operator is the lead on [ __ ]
team and what do you think is the most
important thing one two words for the
community in the second half I'll go
longer than one two words what's very
important to me currently is to refocus
on not the long-term value of the
physical but the short-term value of the
physical based on how the project was
positioned and so I think you'll see a
lot of that I have no expectations of
the community none none what do I want
for the community for them to be happy
and healthy and do whatever the [ __ ]
they want to do I know what my
responsibility is I want to make the
best project I can so that's what I'm
focused on but let there be no com you
know so I don't like Discord because if
words are harder than video right like
you can lose the tone let there be no
confusion play this video over and over
until the day I die I have 0.0
expectations of anybody
quick I have it on myself and that's
what I need to focus on
yeah this is nice I'm just very grateful
for the feedback from today so many of
you are so gracious with your
compliments and your thanks uh I'm
incredibly humbled to be at the helm of
this project I just want to thank you
for coming out I uh I really do
appreciate all of you and I just want
you to know I'm really working hard
really working hard on this committed to
this for the rest of my professional
career if you look carefully under the
hood a lot of the communities are built
because they have impact on the
financial output
and the communities are very grounded in
financial realities of like
self-preserving interests and things of
that nature that is not the case here
you're building Community because you
like each other
and that's [ __ ] the best and I love
you for that
thank you guys
just sitting here wrapping up meetings
after you know the highs of like 200
people you know and then like just
[ __ ] operations meetings here heading
to meet uh CMO for Baylor world and off
to the airport we'll close it out with
ab and Andrew but good day so far
[Music]
so dailyvee I'm sorry I'm not looking in
the camera it's rude but
I'm on the grind 9 30 p.m answering a
prospective client for Vayner you guys
saw what I just did in the back of the
car for 25 minutes tell them tell them
what did I do Adam tell them what I just
did the full 25 minute text it answered
emails I try not to look at your phone
too much so I'm trying it to be creepy
yeah
just [ __ ] grinding airport Gary's
[ __ ] here covet is last year I'm
[ __ ] back it was a lot of fun Shack
is
he's a humble dude that you'll
definitely put the spanking Part Tracy
Morgan thing and they're like what a
like just so good to be part of the
community when I envisioned nfts all the
real life for all of you they're like
What's that P worth well it was the only
way you could have been part of this
let's start with that absolutely and so
just really pumped to be back in quiet
airports at night in the ATL so my
college friends
I saw a bunch of goats did a lot of work
prepped vcon which is our big super
conference with the NFP the only way to
get in is to own a befriend series one
like
kind of feel like I'm in full effect
Vayner X is going
brain garyvee my latest post is a green
screen of me talking about making two
thousand dollars
selling Legos over six months that rant
this style would have got forty thousand
this if I just did a rant right now like
you could make two thousand dollars
selling Legos over six months
237 000 views on Australia this one's at
350 000 right now
when I wake up tomorrow over a million
so Gary Vee is still on his [ __ ] game
understanding that green screen is a
better tactic
the essence sock strategic organic
content
big shout out to vaynermedia you know
what I'm talking about vaynerx you're
learning what I'm talking about so
it's kind of like in my [ __ ] jets are
[ __ ] good
[ __ ] when's the last time on dailyvee
that was happening like jets are good
Knicks are winning
I'm good
[Music]